damien et stéphanie van haltes sont
prêts la fiche port du masque
obligatoire la distanciation sociale et
le sens de circulation attendent les
clients dans leurs boutiques à la ferme
dès le 10 mai la fraiseraie de houdan
rouvrira ses portes après une année
d'adaptation avec la crise sanitaire
le couple d'agriculteurs veut renouer le
contact l'année dernière on a dû
s'adapter un petit peu dans l'urgence on
a fait un drive en fait donc un drive
les gens venir voiture après on trouve
ça un petit peu dommage
notre objectif en faisant de la vente
directe c'est quand même de voir le
consommateur ait pu parler donc cette
année on a dit bon on connaît un peu
mieux le covin donc on prendra les
mesures barrières tout ce qu'il faut
pour être dans les normes sanitaires par
contre on veut rediscuter avec les
clients les gens ont besoin de contacter
contact avec les clients mais aussi
regain vers la production locale
la crise sanitaire a remis au goût du
jour l'achat de fruits et légumes de
saison et surtout près de chez soi
la production locale nous tient à coeur
parce que je pense que c'est important
de revenir au juste valeur là on a
l'impression que les tout le monde
redécouvre la production locale donc
c'est une bonne chose
plus que jamais la fraiseraie de houdon
tient à sa production cette année treize
mille cinq cents pieds de fraisiers ont
à nouveau été plantée avec six variétés
différentes de fraises mais le couple
van halst a aussi tenu à se diversifier
on s'est lancé dans la myrtille parce
qu'aujourd'hui la myrtille c'est un
fruit qui est en vogue qui est très
consommée est très demandé et seulement
10% de la production et française donc
c'est quand même dommage d'acheter de la
myrtille du pérou du chili
sachant qu'on peut potentiellement
produire en france donc on va découvrir
cette production en 2021 seulement
quelques grammes sortiront de cette
nouvelle production dès l'an prochain en
revanche les myrtilles côtoieront les
fraises au sein de la boutique à la
ferme